hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear movie review show
the movie i'm talking about today is one
that i've been wanting to do for a
really long time now interestingly
i had actually never seen this one i
just knew it by reputation like i knew
what happened in it because it comes up
on a lot of
most disturbing movies or movies you
never want to watch twice like things
like that and so i feel like i i was
kind of like well you know eventually i
have to see this you know not only
because
it was really disturbing and i kind of
like to see those but also because it
was written and directed by gaspar noe
and
i've only actually seen a couple of his
other films i think we reviewed climax
not too long ago which i guess was one
of the things that spurred me to want to
go back and watch this one from you know
one of his earlier films and one that is
i mean still probably i kind of feel
like this one is maybe the most
notorious i could be wrong about that
but this is definitely one that
uh was very divisive when it came out
and as far as i can tell is still very
divisive uh there are some people that
are just kind of like uh why would i
want to watch that um
you know what i mean because it's really
not a super pleasant uh movie to sit
through i will say that but
honestly um i kind of found a lot of
artistic merit in it
uh even though it is a deeply unpleasant
watch uh i found it a very very tragic
film i don't think i found it as
difficult to watch maybe because i kind
of knew what to expect
um it is disturbing and it is difficult
to watch i'm not saying i just breezed
through the [ __ ] but
um i guess because i knew
because the reputation of it's been
around so long i mean it came out back
in 2002
and you know people have been talking
about it since then so i kind of knew
what to expect so i was sort of braced
for it i guess so maybe it didn't bother
me as much as
you know if i had just gone into it
completely blind interestingly one thing
that i feel like i knew this fact about
this movie at some point like back in
the old day but i had forgotten about it
so when i started watching it again it's
actually free on 2b if you'd like to
watch it
at least as of this recording
i had actually forgotten that this was
uh the scenes were in reverse
chronological order uh just like memento
now uh you know gaspar noe said that
that was kind of one of the ways that he
got the funding for this movie was by
pitching it as hey i'm gonna do
backward scenes like in memento because
that was such a big success you know the
christopher nolan movie from 2000
um and some people could argue i mean
memento wasn't the first one to do it
either um i'm not sure how many there
were before that but i know that there
was one [ __ ] man i can't remember what
year it came out but it was called the
betrayal and that was kind of the same
thing where they had the scenes in
reverse chronological order so so like i
said it's not so much i don't know it's
not like so much a ripoff but i kind of
feel like gaspar noe said that you know
that's how we got the funding because
momento was such a big success so it
almost kind of seems like oh it was just
like a stunt
but i would argue that i think that
putting the scenes in reverse order
does actually
really bring something
maybe not profound but it does bring
something uh
to what if you played this movie in
the correct order you know what i mean
like the chronological order uh would
just be kind of like a rape revenge
story which and it would still be good
that way but i think that showing it
from you know the aftermath to prior to
the crime happening
i think it really gives it something
that is kind of like hard to put your
finger on i was like reading i guess
roger ebert reviewed it
and he was kind of mixed on it like a
lot of uh you know critics were now he
said that most people will find this
unwatchable uh probably they will
uh you know but he also said that
putting it in reverse order
makes the movie like inherently moral
because you were seeing the aftermath
and the vengeance
first and then you're kind of going back
and seeing like what led up to it and
it does it really does give the movie
like some kind of profundity and it's
also like really tragic because
one of the themes of it i guess is kind
of like and i think one of the reasons
that it's so disturbing to watch too is
that because you know what's going to
happen
and as the scenes go backward uh you
know to prior to this horrible crime
happening um you know what's going to
happen to this character and so it's
doubly tragic because it's almost kind
of like you want to intervene and you
know tell her like what the future is
going to be because you've already seen
it but you can't do that so i think it's
kind of like it really uh brings a
more of like an emotional resonance to
it i guess when you see the aftermath
first
so but it's really weird because when i
first started watching it
and it just pretty much throws you in at
the deep end with this nauseating uh you
know you know gasparnoi he loves his
spinning cameras and his kind of
psychedelic weird red
uh you know imagery and everything and
that is definitely uh here
so they it just kind of throws you in
with this spinning camera and all these
red lights and this really chaotic uh
sort of thing and like all this like
really uh unsettling music and noise and
it's i think it actually i think he did
actually utilize like kind of a sub
audible
type of sounds for this like to make
people feel queasy or anxious or
whatever and uh it definitely does like
in the first part of it but it just kind
of throws you in at the deep end and
when i was watching it i thought to
myself i was like
oh yeah that's right this is backwards
like they it's filmed backwards so after
that
uh i was a lot more engaged because at
first i was just kind of like wait
what's going on and then i was like oh
yeah that's right uh this is actually
the last scene and then we're gonna like
uh you know show what happened prior to
that now interestingly there is one
scene at the beginning that's almost
kind of like a little bit of a prologue
and it just has like this skeezy old
dude
and another skeezy dude and they're
sitting on this bed
in this like gross little apartment
and the older guy is telling the other
guy that he got arrested for sleeping
with his daughter
and then there's this whole thing i mean
as i said one kind of recurring theme in
this movie is quote unquote time
destroys everything so the old guy does
actually say that now this guy is
actually even though he doesn't really
have anything to do with the main
narrative of irreversible
uh he was actually
a character in i believe gaspar noah's
prior movie to this which i think is
called i stand alone i think he was
called the butcher
and so he's kind of like tying it it's
almost like a cinnamon like a [ __ ] up
cinematic universe i guess but he's kind
of like tying it it does kind of tie in
because at the very beginning uh you
know he says there he's talking about
the nightclub where the [ __ ] was
happening and i guess he lives above it
or something like that so he is
in the story but he doesn't really have
anything to do with the narrative but i
i kind of feel like some people that
reviewed the movie were just kind of
like well what were those two guys what
did they have to do with anything that
guy was in his prior movie so he's kind
of like making an odd to the prior movie
because like i said gas mar noise films
set tend to be
but kind of thematically similar i guess
so what we have uh the first thing after
that little kind of prologue scene uh
you know apparently these two guys live
over this nightclub it's like a gay
fetish club called the rectum which
is one of the best uh names for a gay
fetish club of all time i have to say so
uh so yeah uh so they live above that so
then you're kind of like thrown into
that
into this uh you know kind of throbbing
chaotic like club scene
and there's these two guys uh marcus and
pierre and they're obviously very very
uh distraught particularly marcus who
uh it's clear he's pretty um
he's very very like filled with rage and
he's also maybe drunk maybe on something
whatever but he's just like on a [ __ ]
rampage and he's pretty much just going
through this club which almost the way
it's shot and it's like very red and
there's just kind of like all these
you know there's all this like stuff
going on around the margins and so it's
almost kind of like a purgatorial type
of thing and like i said this very
queasy like camera work and this you
know just constant
noise that's kind of like you know just
grinding at your stomach and all this
other stuff and it goes on for like
quite a while so what you're able to
determine is that these two guys are
looking for a dude named latinia i think
is what his name is uh which means the
tapeworm i'm led to assume uh and he's
like a pimp or something now at first
like i said if you don't know anything
about this movie then you don't know why
they're looking for him but they're just
kind of like going through his club
obviously marcus is who's played by uh
vincent cassell actually i've seen him
in a [ __ ] ton of stuff and not just
french movies either because obviously
in case i didn't mention that this is
obviously a french movie but he's been
in some uh you know american or some
other ones as well because i think he
was also in black swan i want to say
maybe that was something that i saw him
in very recently but uh yeah so he's
been at a [ __ ] ton of stuff so you'll
recognize them no problem he's obviously
like the way more motivated of the two
like his friend pierre is kind of trying
to like talk him down like hey man you
know calm down and like you know quit
smacking that dude around and you know
why don't you just you know let's just
go home or let's just go see her or
something like that so he's kind of
trying to you know pull him back from
the brink but uh you know marcus just is
like is not having it he's just going
through this club just like [ __ ]
shaking everyone and punching people and
you know who where is he where is he and
it's like everyone's just kind of
you know everyone's just kind of acting
like it's it's kind of like an
underground club and they're just kind
of like just either making fun of him or
they're just kind of like we don't know
we don't know where he's at blah blah
blah so there's this whole kind of thing
and then like very very uh soon so like
i said this goes on for like a really
long time and then
there's uh one of the two most notorious
and horrific scenes in the movie like
happens very very soon in the movie uh
in the sense that marcus finds who he
thinks is the per is the dude that he's
looking for and uh they start to have
the like this big [ __ ] fight and the
guy gets the better of him and you know
breaks his arm and like he just like
lays on it and like pulls it just like
it's awful and uh so then he's like i'm
gonna rape him actually and then like
his friend comes up with a fire
extinguisher and just beats the bejesus
out of this dude's head it is
horrifying i mean like nowadays this
movie came out in 2002
and apparently they did use some
practical effects for for it uh but they
had to kind of augment it with cgi now
the cgi in 2002 obviously is not as good
as it is nowadays so you can still kind
of tell that it's like cgi but it still
looks really
nasty i mean you know what i mean like
he is just beating the ever loving [ __ ]
out of this dude's face with a big
[ __ ] i mean he's just bashing it
smashing smashing and [ __ ] like that uh
so pierre does that like defending his
friend marcus
so that's kind of like the opening scene
and like i said it's it's a doozy it's a
lot
so then as the story goes on and you go
backwards in time i mean the way this is
shot is really interesting because
it almost he almost shoots it like even
though it's not but he makes it
he shoots it in a way that makes it look
like it's just continuous
shots like that there aren't any cuts
because he's very good at
hiding where the edits are like what
he'll do is like one scene you know like
this scene in the rectum takes place and
then like the camera will like swirl up
toward like a light source which usually
means we're going backward in time and
we're going to the scene that happened
prior to this and so he uses that as a
way to kind of like hide the edit so it
seems like one big continuous shot which
like i think when we talked about his
more recent film climax which i think
came out in 2018 or whatever um same
kind of thing he does these really
really long shots or at least they
appear to be really long shots like
unbroken takes and that's what he does
in this one as well
so
after that scene it starts going back to
you know prior to this where
uh marcus and uh marcus and pierre are
kind of like running through the streets
of paris trying to locate like where
this dude is because they're looking for
this dude so for the next few scenes are
them like running around like
threatening various other people like a
transgender uh prostitute and various
other like gangsters and stuff like that
trying to find out where this dude is
uh and then like as it goes farther and
farther back we get to the source of
their ire i guess uh which is
you know if you know anything about this
movie uh was is the horrible rape and
beating of marcus's girlfriend alex now
alex who's played by monica bellucci and
i believe please correct me if i'm wrong
but i think monica bellucci and vincent
cassell were married in real life at the
time that this movie was made and you
can really tell because they have a real
uh ease with one another i mean the
acting in this is like phenomenal
and it almost seems it just seems very
very naturalistic very realistic it
doesn't even seem like acting at all the
dynamic between the three of these
people because what has ended up
happening is that apparently at some
point in the past
alex
uh dated pierre but then they broke up
and they're still friends but now she's
dating marcus uh you know so marcus and
pierre i'm guests like marcus and pierre
i don't know if they were friends prior
to that or if they just became friends
after because there's some implication
they're not resentful of one another the
two guys but there is a lot of kind of
back and forth um you know before they
get to the party you know after she
leaves the party that's when it happens
but before they get to the party there's
a lot of kind of like
funny like back and forth where he's you
know appears almost kind of like
insinuating that
um you know that marcus stole her from
him because he was more like animalistic
and he and pierre was too cerebral and
didn't know how to get her off and all
these other kind of things it's a very
very sexual movie like a lot of the
discussions uh are very frankly sexual
you know it's a french movie what are
you gonna do
uh you know that's kind of their thing
so so the three so it's almost kind of
like these two guys it's and it's
interesting i really like the way that
they played that dynamic because it
would have been easy i guess
to have
played up the conflict i mean there is
conflict but it's very subtle
um they're still friends they don't seem
there doesn't seem to be any resentment
between any of the three of them or
anything like that but it's pretty clear
that pierre uh the ex is still uh in
love with alex obviously but he doesn't
really i mean he does like i said he
makes little jabs at marcus being like
an animal or being out of control or you
know you don't appreciate her because
look what you're doing because when he
gets to the party he just he drinks a
lot and like [ __ ] you know takes all
the cocaine pretty much and he's just
like
dancing and acting like a spaz and he's
like making out with all these other
chicks and all this other kind of stuff
and you know and pierre's just kind of
like well you know why did you even
bring alex if you're gonna like act this
way you're acting like an ape and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so he's just
trying to like keep him from making an
ass of himself i guess but it's just
kind of like this interesting thing so
because uh when they're at the party
like because um
marcus is acting like an ass
um alex is kind of like yeah i don't
really want to be at this party anymore
you know it's kind of it's kind of lame
i'm gonna go home and pierre's like uh
you know well i'll go with you usually
you shouldn't go by yourself it's very
dangerous and she's like no no just like
don't worry about it you guys have fun
i'm just like going home and i'm kind of
like sick i'm over the scene or whatever
i mean she was having a good time prior
to that but you know marcus was kind of
like acting like a douche
so uh so she starts walking
home or walking back to the train
station rather
and she's in this tunnel like this big
long red tunnel
and uh there you see the pimp latinia
and at this point when you see the guy
that that rapes her
then it's also it's it's doubly bad
because one you know what's gonna happen
and two you realize
that from the beginning of the movie
which is actually the end
the dude that pierre killed with the uh
fire extinguisher was not the right guy
it was just some random i mean you know
it was just some random guy that was
standing next to that guy they just
assumed because they said hey are you
latini and he wouldn't answer so then
they started beating the crap out of him
and they couldn't get any information on
him so i mean pierre ended up just
killing that guy and you find out later
when you see the actual rape happen that
they got the wrong dude that like the
dude that actually did it he didn't even
like you know he was just standing there
going huh holy [ __ ] i just you know what
i mean so again this is like a doubly
like impactful scene because you realize
that's like that's not even the same guy
so yeah so uh latinia is in there and
he's beating the crap out of the
transgender prostitute you've seen
earlier which was actually later uh
whose name is concha
and he's beating the [ __ ] out of her and
then uh you know alex is walking along
like i said just trying to get to the
train but of course uh latinia is just
kind of like oh no i'm just i'm gonna
get in on this and then what ensues
is
probably
i don't even want to say problems i mean
but it's it's definitely up there i'm
going to say is one of the most
harrowing excruciating
scenes in the history of cinema and i
you know i can watch a lot i do have a
hard time
watching rape scenes
but i would argue i mean this one it's
long it's nine minutes that doesn't
sound like a long time
but when you're watching a woman get
horribly raped in an alley for nine
solid minutes and the camera is not
moving
um and it's like real time it seems
endless
now
this scene uh very very difficult to
watch i mean it's just
uh youth
but i would argue i kind of feel like
some critics were kind of like why would
you put that and why did it have to be
so long like it was excessive i don't
really think anybody argued that he was
trying to make it titillating because it
absolutely is not uh it's disgusting and
that's what it's supposed to make you
feel uh it's supposed to make you feel
revulsion and i think he did a really
good job of that but
i don't know i would defend it because
much like and i've talked about this
with other kind of like rape revenge
movies even kind of like you know your
schlocky like exploitation ones like i
spit on your grave from the 1970s which
also has a very very long uh rape scene
in it which is also very difficult to
watch because it's very
very unglamorous and very you know just
it's just very matter of fact and
honestly i would defend
filming it like that more than kind of
sugar coating it or
even glamorizing it or trying to like
soft you know soft pedal it because
honestly i think it's better and more
impactful so i don't know if better is
the word i want to use but um you know i
think it's better and more impactful to
show it the way it really is in real
life show it like this horrible
degrading
you know act and i think it was kind of
necessary
to show it because
you know that's how long it took
um and then it was kind of like that was
sort of like the catalyst which led to
all of this stuff
happening
later in the timeline although earlier
in the movie so you see
you know why because not only does he
rape her like for nine solid minutes but
then he you know and it's anal too like
he anally rapes her and it's it's
horrible and then he just beats the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of her and beats her
into a coma essentially like her face is
just all [ __ ] up
and it's just a horrible horrible scene
to watch as i said it had to be horrific
because you know it it could make the
argument it's like well you know that
happened to her
you know and that almost kind of i don't
want to say it's like justifies but you
can understand like why her boyfriend
marcus was so filled with rage and why
he just spent the rest of the night i
mean yes he was coked up and yes he was
drunk and stuff like that but
um you know why he went so far
and why pierre ended up going so far
because ironically it didn't end up
being marcus that killed the guy who
ended up not even being the rapist it
was pierre who was the one who was
trying to stop marcus from like acting
like you know acting like a fool or
getting his ass kicked but once marcus
got his arm broken
and once somebody was gonna rape marcus
as well um you know pierre came in and
like killed that guy like i said who
didn't even turn out to be uh the rapist
to start with so it was almost kind of
like
it was kind of showing how
just useless it all was in the end
because honestly they never say um and
like i said this is spoilers but this
movie came out like 20 years ago so you
know okay with the program but um you
know and it doesn't really matter anyway
because like i said the end happens at
the beginning so
it's not structured like a normal movie
the sad thing about it is that had they
yeah you know they they never tell you
whether um whether alex survived or not
because basically the last time you see
her um or the first time you see her
rather she's being taken away on a
stretcher and her face is all [ __ ] up
and bloody and they say she's in a coma
but they never say if she like lives or
dies or anything like that so
you know and and it's sad that
marcus um didn't just go to the hospital
to be with her because you know he might
never see her again she might not
survive um but he just kind of went off
on this
i you know i guess because of his ego or
whatever and he just went off on this
[ __ ]
rampage uh looking for the guy that did
it to her which is understandable but it
ended up being
pointless in the end i mean he not only
not only did that guy i mean i'm not
saying the guy that got killed was a
great dude but he wasn't the actual
rapist he wasn't the guy that he was
going after um but in the course of
looking for that guy uh marcus also like
beat the [ __ ] out of a taxi driver stole
a taxi cab beat the [ __ ] out of a
prostitute like but you know what i mean
so he did like a bunch of other [ __ ]
up [ __ ] too like in this quest for
vengeance which ended up being
ultimately pointless
and it's you know so it's really sad
like had he not
been that way uh you know obviously he
could have maybe you know gone to the
hospital to be with her which probably
she would have appreciated more than
having him running through the streets
of paris being a [ __ ] terror and just
compounding the violence but you know
that's kind of what the point of the
movie is the interesting thing too is
that by putting the movie in reverse
order
um so obviously the horrific [ __ ]
happens like very very soon in the movie
and then you get these scenes of them
getting ready to go to the party you
know uh marcus and alex and they're like
being playful and having sex and maybe
she has maybe she's pregnant she's like
really excited about it he's like
excited about the possibility and
they're just kind of like you know
they're they're just being in love and
it's just kind of like this cool thing
and it's like the the more the movie
goes on and you know the more
before the rape uh you know scenes that
you see like the sadder and sadder it
gets because it's almost kind of like
this woman's fate is sealed you've
already seen it and there's nothing that
she can do
to
you know alleviate it to get away from
it i mean she's doomed and that makes it
like a really really i mean i found it
like a really emotionally wrenching like
thing to watch because it's just like as
it goes on it just gets sadder and
sadder and it's kind of creepy too
because
you know as the earlier scenes come
forth like toward the end of the movie
there's all of this like foreshadowing
because and it's not even foreshadowing
because we already know what happened
but the characters don't so
she's you know for example she's telling
marcus she's like i had this really
weird dream that i was in this red
tunnel which you know the red tunnel
where's where she ended up getting raped
and she's like and the um
you know in the tunnel like ended up
splitting off into two so i'm guessing
that that being some kind of like weird
symbol for
either her life before and after the
rape or it could be like the line
between life and death because maybe she
didn't survive so there's all this kind
of stuff that
is you know in a normal narrative would
be foreshadowing but it's made a lot
more impactful because it's not
foreshadowing we already know what
happens they don't so
you know when she says something like
that you're just kind of like heart it's
heartbreaking because you already know
that her fate is sealed and there's
nothing that she can do about it
interestingly too i kind of feel like a
lot of the
conversations
that you know like when they're in the
subway on the way to the party
for example with pierre and they're
having all these conversations and she's
talking about like i guess her and
pierre talking about how maybe their sex
life didn't work out and um she's
talking about oh well you know sex is
better if you're just not worrying about
like your partner because if you worry
about that then you will kind of like
lock up you won't you know loosen up or
whatever so it's she's like it's better
to be selfish which when she says
something like that and you have already
seen the horrible [ __ ] [ __ ] that
happens to her it's just kind of like
this horrible thing because it's almost
like she's talking about her rapist
and there's like really kind of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] too like later on where you know
her and
marcus like they've been taking a nap or
whatever and they're both like in bed
naked and they're just like kind of
playing around and they're like oh yeah
we have to get up and go to the party
and stuff and he
you know says some stuff like oh he's
gonna you know he he wants to [ __ ] her
in the ass and all this other kind of
stuff which like i said ends up
happening to her later on so it's like i
don't know if gaspar noe like was maybe
making some i'm not really sure if he
was making some kind of statement that
you know like the stuff that marcus was
saying to her the way he was treating
her i mean obviously he loved her but
the things that he was saying were not
really a difference of kind to what the
rapist was saying or the attitudes that
the rapist would just a difference of
degree i'm not really sure if that was
his intention but that's kind of like
what i got from it because he was saying
you know marcus was saying some kind of
similar things to her that the rapist
said later on but just like in a
different context or like not as extreme
or something like that so i don't know
that's kind of what i got from it maybe
i'm not really sure if i'm reading
something into it that isn't there or
maybe that's just my own interpretation
or whatever
but um there definitely is
a lot of very obvious uh you know things
that happen in the conversations later
on in the movie meaning earlier in the
timeline
that
you know foreshadow or that kind of like
you know is kind of like a smaller
version i guess of like the horrific
[ __ ] that happens later on so there's
like a lot of that kind of stuff so i
don't even know if you can call it
foreshadowing it's post shadowing i
don't know is there a word for that i'm
sure there probably is but yeah so this
movie as i said even nowadays you know
and this came out 20 years ago i think
if i'm not mistaken i'm pretty sure that
this is still
one of his most controversial movies
pretty i mean if you go around the
internet and there's like all these kind
of lists of you know oh most disturbing
movies and this is usually on there and
uh for a very good reason as i said this
is one of those movies that i know that
there are some people that just want to
watch movies and just
you know have it be fun or have it be
entertaining or something like that and
it's like why the [ __ ] would i want to
watch a nine minute scene of like this
woman getting horribly brutally raped
and her face beaten in um you know and i
get that like i'm not judging like if
you don't want to watch that because
like i said it's not this is not a movie
for entertainment this is a movie that's
you know trying to be provocative it's
trying to say something it's you know so
i you know i i like both kinds of movies
and it's this is not a fun watch but i'm
actually
glad i watched it because there was a
lot
in it that really resonated with me i
guess um about i don't know about about
fate about uh you know revenge about i
don't know it's just there was something
about it that really like um
i don't know it really like kind of got
to me i guess and so i can see why a lot
of people bring this one up when they're
talking about
you know really disturbing films or but
ones that are totally worth watching i
think but like i said i would not blame
you in the least uh if you didn't want
to watch a movie with scenes like this
in it you know i mean other than those
two scenes like i said the rape scene
and the scene where the guy gets beaten
to death with the um
fire extinguisher that's pretty much um
you know the most disturbing scenes the
rest of it is not
that graphic there is a lot of violence
in this and there is a lot of just
people being the worst
um
this movie has gotten a lot of
accusations of homophobia uh because the
rapist is actually gay and a lot of the
stuff and so even like so he rapes a
woman which you know so a lot of people
were just kind of like well why would
that happen why you know and the scene
that happens in the rectum the gay club
it's like you could probably yeah i mean
you know gaspar noe said i'm not
homophobic he's like i was in that scene
uh you know so
i don't like have anything against that
but
it's i don't know it does really kind of
how you feel about that is
you know and i can understand if you
don't want to watch it for that too
because i mean honestly
there is a lot of kind of like um
slurs against gay people in this like a
lot and there's a lot of that going on
in here but like i said the people in it
are not great people it's not like it's
the hero like you know what i mean this
really has no heroes in it other than
you know other than alex who is just
kind of like an innocent person who just
has this horrible thing happen but
everybody else
is kind of terrible so these are kind of
terrible people doing terrible things
and like not solving any problems uh so
it's one of those kind of movies so you
really kind of have to be in the mood
for it this actually did win a bunch of
awards but as i said critics were very
very divided i think when it uh
premiered at can
it was nominated for the palm door i
don't think it won
but it was nominated and uh they had
about half walkouts uh
you know what i mean half the half the
audience walked out pretty much every
screening uh i get it if you go into it
not knowing what to expect as i said it
didn't bother me that much because i had
heard so much about this movie over the
years and it's gaspar noe and i'd seen
some of his other stuff so i kind of
knew what to expect so yes it's
harrowing yes it's excruciating to watch
yes it's very painful to watch
but
i you know i knew what was coming so it
didn't bother me as much as maybe it
would bother somebody that was just at
can being like oh okay let's go watch
this french film and then like what the
[ __ ] you know what i made but why is why
do i want to kill myself now oh my god
this is like so yeah it's a bummer uh so
yeah but uh yeah so if you've seen it i
kind of feel like a lot of people have
seen this i can't believe it took me
this long to get around to it i think
that i was putting it off because i knew
that it had like a really horrible rape
scene in it and i have like i said i
that's one of the only things i have a
hard time watching i can't i can watch
them but they bother me you know rape
cruelty to animals anything having to do
with poop
or eating vomit i'm just i'm not into
that um so those are the hearts i can't
watch pretty much anything else but
those things kind of bother me but uh
yeah so i think that's why i was kind of
putting it off for so long because i'm
like man i'm really gonna have to be
like in the mood to watch that
but i'm glad i finally did watch it
because it actually is
i'm not gonna say it's uplifting because
it's not um although i guess there's
like a reading of it that sort of maybe
could be uplifting if you looked at it
in a in a weird way but it's pretty
soul-crushing i think i found it pretty
soul-crushing but as i said i'm kind of
i'm glad i watched it uh but yeah so let
me know what you think of irreversible
in the comments or if you are a fan of
gasparnoi or really really hate his
movies i'd be curious to know uh what
you think about it in the comments
another thing too i think is this is the
last flickers of fear i'm gonna do for
january and i decided that for some
months of the year just to make things
easier for me like for as far as picking
movies and stuff i decided some months i
was going to do like a theme
at least from the movies i'm not going
to do like the book reviews because
that'd be too hard but uh so for
february i actually wanted to do a folk
horror february because as i mentioned
on a couple of my last
videos uh there's a really good
documentary on shutter called woodlands
dark and days bewitched and it's all
about folk horror and i kind of uh saw a
lot of movies in there that i wanted to
watch that i wanted to add to my list
and there's a [ __ ] ton of them on
shutter and uh on to be and stuff so i
made like a list for february so for
february i think it's eight movies i
guess it's eight movies so i'm gonna do
like eight folk horror movies for the
month of february uh but we'll see i'm
not entirely sure which ones i'm gonna
do yet it's gonna depend on i got a list
of ones i wanna do but it's gonna depend
on availability so but we'll see how it
goes uh because that's a genre that i
really felt like i needed to do more of
so
hopefully you guys enjoy that and that
will do it for this flickers of fear i
will see you guys on the next one
bye